it's gonna jump into it here you play as
po that's pole right there and the white
shirt and the yellow shorts this is her
apartment swing as you navigate the menu
here you sort of explore her apartment
so she is a dream Exorcist that sounds
like that sounds like she made that up
yeah she's from a clan called the silk
they've been dream exorcists for like
hundreds of years this isn't an
alternate future city called San low so
in her day-to-day life you would just go
to her if you have nightmares she can go
into your nightmares and clean out the
demons but basically the story the game
is the entire city is locked into
nightmares and they can't wake up and
obviously she's specially equipped to
deal with that and she works with these
ghosts these are her familiars so these
are these will help you in combat I
mention it's a twin-stick shooter I'm
gonna jump in a combat real soon so you
don't just see the shell got it would be
be quiet so you can listen to the music
and play utter I mean the soundtrack is
really incredible like there's such a
good and she dashed forever yeah there's
just a bow down a couple beats of cool
down afterwards bboy mr. maestro says
last night he dreamt he was in an nwa
music video I said I felt uncomfortable
at first but easy he was cool alright
alright keep risin that easy e was RFK
eazy-e you think yeah he seems like he'd
be the biggest wild card he definitely
had the most EMF about him job two
nights ago Seth Frost was dreaming about
fighting the alien out getting under
health emptying his coat do that and
then so that's the curse you can't
change them though Oh God dang it haha
oh no I'm okay how much longer is he
gonna survive Pope he thought of that
slow down time let me slow down fo oh
good job am i dead already another try
okay oh so there's no continue you once
you die you start over yeah so if had
you made it to the second stage you
would start on stage oh you don't have
to start from them so how do I know you
sorry at this no it's trying to do my
help whoa whoa whoa whoa she left bumper
Oh tape also it looks like you lost your
master ghost that was a bug i noticed
Earl
that I forgot to tell you thanks chief
the game shipping with bugs uh probably
the Russian word what game doesn't
should buy that's absolutely haha get
these things off in the holy crap this
is a challenge so you should yeah just
keep your key check keep your guns
blazing oh I think this is part of it
though like these people who like I love
these games and part of it I love is
like the mastery ask me exactly so like
I I was never into that type of game
until dark souls really suck me in is
like the feeling of accomplishment after
you died a dozen times when you finally
figure out how to beat a section of the
level we don't break your console by
then this is really incredible yeah this
is not a lot of genres left where don't
one is over and over and over again and
I feel like this is one of them yeah
more doors pretty difficult no way at
the start of me like you get opee pretty
fast in that game maybe haven't played
enough you for that's pretty open world
though there's a lot to you yeah if you
play Phoenix rage that's that's pretty
though I like that you're lumping these
all these keys so can I shoot faster its
assets it's always a set pace yeah that
shooting is set to the sound ok got very
good good keep just keep Ilona passed
away hey watch I'm just like David
fighting games just run away ja we don't
want it oh my god yeah this is uh yeah
you're not invincible as yeah she
thirsty yeah you might want to change
that is not well if you dash your like
you're basically definitely going to get
hit people you versal ha ha universally
expect to be invincible drug down no we
had that we had that and we found that
was not hard enough day would you like
to send a shot yeah Dave you should give
a shadow gobbler what are the control
what oh god yeah he does he move right
to that right bumpers dash I got this
and then if I'm trigger to slow down
time left left trigger when you have
your special attack left bumper to cycle
through your ghosts I think your get
that first time I see Dave playing video
game I'm impressed I'm like he doesn't
just make money off the stuff yeah I'm
just a [ __ ] talker I every well to be
fair I mean you're a really good [ __ ]
talker like my one of my favorite games
from two years ago sine Mora yep mmm its
sign more then a [ __ ] yeah
I said ana Moura so good Kimbra super
cute a singer who's got time to warn
I'll promise these games man if you
should put your ghosts in those idols
how do you oh yeah well I ameya right
trigger whoa no I'm all there's a slow
down I'm just kidding yeah that's not
the health one if you played this level
what what would you pick the help um so
the first thing I would do is not play
with the cursed load on I would be
switching it up a lot I switched to help
a lot because i suck and I got end up
needing it so this is actually a good
spread that Dave's done he's done the
attack and the health one nice work Dave
even though they did it by accident oh
god like what a higher score should I
kept track he now these are like when it
comes like events like I own or just in
general it's great to have these kind of
games especially have like I've seen
events have resogun challenges Bailey
are here for iron galaxy not CEO yeah so
on dive cake there's a stupid scoring no
I tell me that resogun alright Dave
watch out for the lotuses no target low
to get out of there oh my head I think I
got farther take again do get this one
join a back out and get the mass almost
in there I'm goblet oh god like we're
good um so if you want to look up so mq
i was mentioning is the artist he has
his own bandcamp page at em dash Q
bandcamp com he's got a bunch of albums
so if you like what you hear go support
him he's a badass I am vaguely
infuriated that I can't my shootings
governed by the music thank you I I did
feel I want music to be faster that's
only something in this life depends a
level really yeah so you sort of that is
there one where it's just constant
barrage yeah it does that's level 3 to
make it more challenging this way I do
as you appreciate is darude sandstorm in
this game not yet the final countdown we
haven't uh delve the rock band style
license dlc yet are you guys gonna do
any post for this job ah I would hope I
want away love to do uh release some
more levels release if I get my mail
with the one at all's I got to get my
mail a up we'll see yeah you do I'll be
careful I'm showing for every tube video
that does the one hit kill mode it never
dies yep
budge with his health me all his help
mele mele oh my god it's the worst have
you done better now the Lotus this love
and come up yet have they lotus is our
Africa oh my god so if I would a day I
would save up my melee to get my sword
up oh now you go they go time Tech
children lotuses all right you've
already done better than last time are
you just gonna survive David's don't
move around too much don't tell me what
to do every day I'm my own blaster David
ah he's like oh look at the pretty slow
down I just stay by the help I'm just
good i think if i go to help no matter
what if a long as I pick up help at all
times you actually I got this figured
out go to get help I do like the design
of how the health doesn't just come from
the center it actually stress yourself
out see if you come camping one here oh
no you got it my whole plan is a sunder
I believe you survived don't know [ __ ]
it up no it's all right I'm so godlike
sort of those thumbtacks or needle uh
needles my eyes are watering holes yeah
my life all right don't blink the eyes
Kirk I'll help you up update heal up how
do you do that oh jesus oh god how do
you uh oh my eyes oh just might hire
again oh my god does my health insurance
oh oh number seizures oh never sued
again